What is the capital of Brazil?
Of course.
Its capital is Brasilia.
Which is the capital of Argentina,
Subparagraph b?
Its capital is Buenos Aires.
Do you know which is the capital of Colombia?
.
The capital of Colombia is Bogotá.
You know which is the capital of Mexico,
Subparagraph b?
Its capital is Mexico City.
What is the capital of Peru?
That's right.
Its capital is the city of Lima.
Let's continue.
Do you know which is the capital of Chile?
Inciso c.
It is Santiago de Chile.
What is the capital of Venezuela?
Very good.
Its capital is.
Can you identify which is the capital of the United States?
A bit difficult,
isn't it?
Its capital is Washington DC.
What is the capital of Cuba?
Option b is restriction.
What will be the correct answer?
The correct answer is As.
What is the capital of the Dominican Republic?
Exactly.
Its capital is Santo Domingo.
Do you identify which is the capital of Costa Rica?
Its capital is San José.
What is the capital of Uruguay?
Excellent.
The capital of Uruguay is.
Next.
Which is the capital of Guatemala?
Subparagraph b?
Its capital is Guatemala City.
Will you be able to guess which is the capital of Ecuador?
Perfect.
Its capital is Quito.
Let's increase the difficulty a little.
What is the capital of Nicaragua?
This is the city of Managua.
What is the capital of Panama?
You are correct.
Its capital is Panama City.
You are very close to completing this challenge.
What is the capital of Haiti?
Very good.
It is Port-au-Prince.
Finally,
what is the capital of Bolivia?
.
The official capital of Bolivia is Sucre.